ça a toujours été là j'ai toujours
toujours crayonné toujours dessiné
toujours créé des petits objets il me
juste pas envie juste parce que je tiens
j'avais une idée ce jour la nati perez a
en tête un pendentif
elle a sorti le plateau de pierres semi
précieuses elle laisse son imagination
faire le reste
ça pourrait être l'opal ou bien
labradorite ou même la pierre de soleil
les trois l'e3 pourrait convenir après
j'ai une petite préférence pour l'opal
pour ce pendentif nati perez a étudié à
la cité de l'or à saint-amand montrond
dans le cher
elle a en poche un brevet des métiers
d'art en art du bijou et du joyau
elle est aussi meilleur apprenti de
france en sertissage de haute joaillerie
elle a d'abord travaillé chez un
bijoutier puis il ya deux ans elle
s'installe à son compte
ce que j'aime c'est partir d'un matériel
brut donc un lingot un filou vraiment un
tas de d'anciens bijoux et de partir de
presque zéro en fait et d'en créer
quelque chose de totalement nouveau
la transformation de la matière la
longer la forgette à souder
la percée l'acier la jeune créatrice
travail l'or l'argent
elle peut refaire à l'identique la
boucle d'oreille perdu réparer une bague
ou donner une seconde vie aux bijoux il
ya deux alliances une chaîne cassée des
petits pendentifs voilà tout ça en or
jaune ou en or gris et donc je verrai
utiliser ça pour la clientèle m'a
demandé de lui créer une bague que je
lui ai fait un croquis et une maquette
en laiton pour qu'elle puisse l'essayer
donc voilà ce que je lui ai créé et donc
il y aura un anneau en or jaune et un
anneau en or blanc les créations de nadi
perez sont uniques
elles sont à découvrir dans son atelier
ou sur son site internet